walkners Political Correctness cancel
culture und ähnliches mehr deshalb kann
ich nicht ganz ihre Erwartungen bedienen
dass ich hier wütend auftrete denn das
bringt wenig wütend waren wir jetzt
schon lange Zeit oder waren enttäuscht
oder irgendwie frustriert über diese
Entwicklungen wenn man diese Figur dich
gefriert dann weiß man was auf dem Spiel
steht und dann weiß man wo gegen diese
Kulturkampf eigentlich gekämpft wird
indem wir mittendrin sind und ich kann
es in einem Satz im Grunde sagen alt
steht für Erfahrung steht für Tradition
steht auch für Urteilskraft weiß steht
für unsere europäische Rationalität für
Wissenschaft steht für technischen
Fortschritt ja und Männlichkeit steht
für Risikobereitschaft für Mut und
letztlich auch für die Energie sich
durchzusetzen und gegen all das wird im
Grunde ge